yeah welcome to this video I'll do some
cubits in here yeah Nakamura is playing
a couple of games he on a cc and started
out with some Bulleit games i'm not
quite sure what time control will get
here if he continues to play bullied or
switch its to some longer time controls
he tends to to mix us to mix this up I'm
always difficult for me to be honest and
you really need to get into yeah the
right rhythm form for the time control
so I cannot really switch from five
minute to bullet and all back bottom he
doesn't seem to care so we've got bullet
so don't take it too seriously and enjoy
the ride get a Sicilian here night off
and one will play with f4 and yeah g4g
five so white for a [ __ ] side attack
and f6 is the possibility at some point
or you can I measures the pawns for it
you can also try for a piece on driven
attack well this looks am dangerous for
black the e6 square d 5 square but of
course it's a bullet game it's fit I
tried to do some some comentary but it's
mostly for the fun of it it's not like
I'm you should expect to to to learn a
lot so I widest got the c6 pawn but you
just sacrifice but it's very active of
course on the kingside ya think on takes
now and I'll see 7 is hanging which like
so I know what tries to get the pieces
towards the king he's playing a
grandmaster from francium um not quite
sure who that is it's very high rating
and one minute okay now cameras rating
is two thousand and hundred almost but
alyssa yes simply out of this world in
human terms the 2500 is really really
really high
I mean the best whatever would that I
got is like 225 also like 60 points
lower this guy ass um yeah 90 f7
checkmating yeah fun smothered mate yep
like would have forgot the huge problems
timewise but this is this is nice of
course it's also very big big Fork okay
nakamura trying for the it's not that
yeah very nice tactic it's like I'm
where I'm moving this not me this is a
nice check made he was was too quick
didn't didn't didn't see it in the game
okay it's always moving pretty much
instantly so um but he often sees those
tricks like a second later and and shows
them afterwards okay let's see if it
continues with one minute on if there
are some some other games yeah if he
doesn't get a game on one minute uh it's
it's that little strange something there
are lots of players some in this in this
pool all the time so he really should
gain get games quickly only hope is not
leaving on the hill then this would be a
four minute video would be a yeah a bit
short ok the next game some guy with
2400 yeah this is not too bad I mean it
looks like 400 points less of it sir but
this is really a pretty high rating I
really need to play well and good it to
to get to this writing so I'm not saying
I'm a great bullet player but
it's not this not terrible relief this
tooth 24 okay we got them French
exchange where Nakamura Castle kingside
Queen side and we have fun opposite side
counseling and black is already in
taking on the the G file but white has
the beef are also open so we into some
some technical tricks now I guess night
h3 could be a could be a quite good move
not now I guess I mean okay can play it
but it's not like winning dumb yep I can
try all kinds of tricks now okay it's a
fork opinion I'm sorry it's a pin young
I think white why do a loose material
now yeah this was also a so we're oak
brook now gently i only spent 25 seconds
white resigns yeah it's just a nice
rogue and yeah 26 seconds 20 seconds on
the clock is also not not bad at all
yeah that's the big problem if you play
I mean besides the fact that he's simply
am very strong this the simple speed I
mean I managed a managed a couple of
really good positions and then five
minute against him but very often lost
on time or if the time got to get good
low then he's is simply I'm so good with
tactics that you are have huge problems
in converting any cans of advantage yeah
it's a bit dumb it always takes a while
here some of the new game starts I'm
sorry but not much that I can do I
wonder if it really takes so long for
him to to get a game or if you just stem
takes little breaks between the games
I'm doing and it's doing some other
other things
it's impossible to tell really if it
okay add this this guy again from France
so maybe another singin okay he's
actually playing rather mainline
openings here and it's not playing like
yeah his weird stuff which also yeah
very often this is played this looks
like a really normal chess game okay
Sicilian wear black can play the cook d5
and also this H fine sorry okay why do I
took the porn back to cut the aged
father so it's got some practical
chances but the problem is that the
bishop won't be seven is really a dead
piece if the bishop would put play in
some way then it would be quite okay for
black but the bishop is simply something
very bad head white will be the one now
to get an attack on the queenside I
guess alright just an exchange sack but
yeah guess queen bee three is quite
strong now okay I didn't see this at all
I Quincy 627 friends made now so instead
i made i don't think so gap black has no
attack but ruby three yeah objectively
speaking this is not working for white i
guess but it's very very dangerous
looking right oh we counter-attack try
try F for us also hanging oh this is
made this is made yellow it was down to
one second something and yeah I think I
could have taken on that form I'm sure
can I move the pieces here any I can
I mean okay it's a bit silly to analyze
and Lotus gambit he could have taken now
on non f4 but King g2 and then there's
nothing maybe Queen d2 bag could be a
draw right it could be a draw oh no
black can actually made black and win
here with taking on f4 I'll see it's
mainly for move sir I just switched on
the comm quickly do to speed this up
yeah it's just made GTX a fraud check
right King every row gauge free and
kingi for the squeegee too yeah like a
son like his meeting all right so but
two seconds is a bit um a bit too too
too little time ok the the Duncan
suttles system again with tweetsie eight
and so on this is surprisingly resilient
ya think of some key plays though some
set up some that have been placed in the
70s by this Canadian Grand Master Duncan
suttles you place the circle I dolphin
in in Blitzen bullet and with quite some
success guess it's also a little bit of
them yeah Marsh 22 when coover ways
obviously residing nowadays and okay but
this this looks like a very very bad
position for black White's got to
attacking nodes that is even time while
it's not so bad off yeah very very very
dangerous you should to e6 wat an idea
and not play well of course Black has
covered this and um whoo yeah very hard
to keep this position together why just
pushes the pawns won't black yeah black
sacrifice to appease but yeah well I
still in bullet terms is still in
the game but okay why does winning you
should manage this really he's also got
13 seconds yeah why should win he ever
gone left one push down okay activated
the king yeah nice nicely played six
seconds this might get might get still
tricky if he doesn't manager made it
will get to get tricky shocked me okay
here he managed so we a good gamer white
I guess he got a very nice position with
the Knights and waiting on d6 andy sixx
some Oh quite not as I guess what I was
I was referring to the size of the
Duncan subtle system this is this we had
kind of set up with ruth quincy aid
where you quickly get this bishop okay i
cannot draw any errors unfortunately if
i'm not an examiner of the game only
knock i could draw hours this Bishop h3
idea is quite funny so you get rid of
this bishop if white castles short and
yeah well it's hard to do without castle
short long run and what black is doing
is usually knight c6 and e5 and yeah
this is ok ok ok just left the server
this is unfortunate so on we don't get
any more nakamura games but i can try to
to check on what's going on who else is
playing we've got garage chef playing
some rated slightly below arm 2700 and
his playing uh yes a little bullet also
unfortunately no our 5-minute games on
or rapids am but i can do any really
meaningful comentary the some looking at
the bullet games is really just for for
entertainment purposes but let's see
what happens here
as you see I'm garage chef Ian this one
minute who has got to 2600 while a
camera is got two 9 almost so the
cameras ratings really exceptionally
high at the moment I don't think that
garage chef okay is in comparison he's
worse but it's really a very strong
bullet player so the difference is not
not so i right yeah we see is very
tricky for it but but you lost some time
all right and I will check off if we got
some some some five-minute games with
some some high rated players let's let's
check I whilst you are displaying here
from online chess online chess lessons
he's playing an international master
here stewardess black and he's playing a
yeah my personal nemesis on icc Oleg us
this is international master creep creep
one myself if I'm right from latvia and
this is the the player I've got the
worst score on icc against i think i
want one game out of 50 or something I
even if but its course then I have
better scores against a strong
grandmasters really absolutely cannot
play against the sky don't know ok and
here here the white play ask our next
report extra d5 pawn this all happened
out of the exchange variation of the
Kings Indian he always plays the
exchange variation cream proven Asif
yeah what should be the winning years
got the deep on and yeah Black has some
the pieces here on the back rank so it
very easily will will lose some some of
this rook c8 now I'm destro gay too so
black has Scott yes some counter threats
on d too so maybe this is not the the
easiest solution yeah I was just about
to suggest this because nothing like a
black needs to exchange oh well you you
get an exchange in any way either black
takes on c4 hey let's see he'll also the
rope to be taken but then now black some
corn structure is really compromised and
why it's got these two points now this
might get to get ugly yeah rugby 794
probably 194 immediately is also strong
track and then the points are just
rolling maybe you can move them and now
but rook hu is so a bit yeah this is
also good I guess attacking the bishop
now yeah right er 94 so there would have
been ruki one czechian okay every white
can just them yeah like I just push the
pawns now I guess d 6 or 6 p-6 look so
looks fine also probably both moves are
winning yeah now what can just run to d5
Joe and win with the pawns some six
knots or threatening checkmate should be
hopeless really you can always check the
night on d 2 for the pawn and you've got
these two points which really get you a
new queen it's not only am winning
material that will be an extra Queen
jo bhi major yeah the end of this game
very am clean technique here by the
white player it wasn't exactly a
difficult but still still a good job
let's see who else is on there it
actually tells me that the camera is on
again no its own now this possum what's
a technical error so on yeah don't have
any high-profile games that are that I
want to really really look at it's not
sure I doubt I don't know these guys
really ninguno for instance can have a
look here yeah it's um GM from from Cuba
living in Miami a teaching chess in the
Baja most of all yeah well things that
you could do yeah there's simply not
much going on what can you do okay this
video is now 18 minutes so it's some
it's a it's a dead shot so um it's a
bonus I know maybe I should I could I
could play some myself but um yeah came
game starting let's see if I can get
some three minutes games going here to
make this a decent video length yeah
let's let's see what happens we got an
Enzo probably I'm okay yeah the nums oh
and time
play three m92 covering of the sea 39
okay I'll take the bishop am ok you
retreat the salts are possible of course
but it also allows why to get some
advantage in the center with d5 so i
will have some space advantage yeah yeah
probably he wants to play b5 yeah why
didn't in general has two ideas he can
play the light of g3 Bishop e2 or g3 and
fianchetto not sure ok I'll try for the
fianchetto ok ok let's say let's let's
say I take here and then play Bishop /
to ji tun yeah it's little porn I mean I
can take here now oh is this too risky
that my bishop get strapped down mmm
yeah maybe ok and this was probably not
the best idea ever he's got a nice
center now yeah I wanted to take on b5
but you can just um you can just grab
this and imprison my bishop on a aid
yeah I just gains time on my minor
pieces I want to try a Bishop to g5 a
possible and then 93 getting some
pressure on d5 yeah what should I do now
I mean it doesn't make any sense to
exchange the rock again so this might
also allow be should be too okay need to
get something going on d5 otherwise
episodes really ugly yeah he's attacking
e to so cannot win swindon material on
d5 yeah now I have 96 probably using the
week square yeah I so much fun to play
against the center and I'm not so bad
really but don't worry yeah yeah I know
okay maybe I can play something like
this stopping the deep own on to go from
Queen to h5 using my pieces here on the
kingside he doesn't have anything
developed right okay because I need to
take this now trying to placate Knight
to c4 would be very helpful why it's got
95 coming
ok trying to pin them on on the rock um
yeah I'm just blundering my queen here
what the [ __ ] the heck all right why
resins okay this wasn't just of sex for
hire yeah I was simply too slow also the
first game is always always very
critical so Dutch defense here this is
probably playing the older Stonewall
even yeah the d6 is also possible of
course okay it's going for very quick um
Bishop maneuver here to h5 like also
hasn't played c6 which is slightly
irritating okay it it's plagued now yeah
white usually wants to get the Knights
on d3 and f3 this kind of setup to
control e5 control f for the Knights
have fun simply the best coverage in
this position of all this black squares
in term ducks grass and its really
sometimes the question if this Bishop is
doing so much because some you can never
really take here because of e takes a
three and then the e [ __ ] pressure gets
gets too much yeah maybe he's playing
for g5 really it's possible okay I just
said that it's not good but we did it he
captured anyway it's maybe sometimes an
idea if you get something on deform
what's still um I grew account believe
it it should be very nice game now for
white with pressure on e6 mmm yeah f4
let's let's just come
this the e pawn will stay weak I don't
need to rush things fo and 95 will be
nice okay so f4 to keep the porn really
on only six and then 95 should be very
nice don't really see how it covers is
69 okay with the passive move this is
possible 9700 rookie 8 or something but
it's not dumb ok ok rookie six it will
take here and night takes I don't know
hmm ok i will try to to get rid of this
active rook this is some really annoying
Peter the rock and now i think i need
she needs to exchange it ok let's grab
here and here now take on e6 or do I
have something better I forgot here why
does he go Quincy three I can just take
and Queenie too hmm Bishop to f1 ok it's
got all the way back here Bishop f3 you
would need to go to be five you can see
fall so but ok this is all very nice I
can take a b7 I can take a six and and
so on I thought a form but a for Quincy
form
mm yeah it's all very good all this is
also a good move so it's spoiled for
choice here also got tonight to deform
with f5 hanging shouldn't be too bad
really yeah I want two points now I mean
I had no Swan pond down so it's um it's
um just an extra corn at the moment time
morning okay so let's let's see the c6
bonus little weakness yeah i know i can
i can enter your own d8 ok so now maybe
take here and set up this blockade now
the porn i was a bit sloppy here really
yeah this was really bad flavor me so I
can be glad that I is it taking this now
time wise it's very nice but the
position I spoiled ok now it's also
position wise winning again I ride yeah
crappy game at the end and they had it
quite a nice position for this for this
pawn really taking taking here's always
very questionable because you you give
give wide really lots of play with um
with with the fall and the good bishop
yeah so we're going to have now when you
know it's a bit a bit of a mixed tape
right some knockout blitzing some other
stuff and then too we are not too
brilliant three minute games by me hope
you enjoyed it anyway and yeah coverage
will continue soon yeah